[Musique]
étrangère
nous avons vu beaucoup d'intérêts quand la convoitise a frappé,
je veux dire, c'était comme un tsunami vous
savez et je pense que cela avait à voir avec beaucoup
de maladies mentales qui se produisaient,
euh et les gens essayaient de chercher
leur  propres solutions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au lieu de l'utiliser à des fins récréatives, j'ai
découvert qu'il y avait vraiment d'
énormes avantages pour la santé mentale à l'utiliser à des fins
thérapeutiques et cela m'a en quelque sorte aidé à
surmonter ma dépression, ce qui
m'a définitivement aidé à gérer mes relations
sociales.  anxiété
[Musique]
avec moi
jusqu'à ce que nous puissions arrêter, je vous souhaite le meilleur dans
la thérapie à la psilocybine, mon objectif est d'être
présent
pour ne pas diriger pour être un assistant, vous savez,
et créer un espace de sécurité, de
protection et de soins
et laisser tout ce qui se passe.  dans
cette bulle, cela se produit pour le client,
c'est